my all-time favorite shepherd's pie
what's the secret
behind a really good shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
growing in it
so we're going to use leeks and onions
and they'll start browning off the mints
you know no color no flavor i've never
forgotten that you know that yep
so good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks
greasy and cheap and nasty
they don't want that julie and i know
you don't do cheap or nasty
let me clear your peelings now huh all
right thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is there
no don't be cheeky
i remember your amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back no
sometimes they complained that there
were
you never ever got a complaint no how
long have you worked at that restaurant
for
six shoes six years oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version
of nanny's shepherd's pie dad shouldn't
manny be doing the cooking because she's
the better cook
excuse me right mum would you would you
top our uh our onion please daddy
yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna water
in there we've got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding
let's just separate it for you um
how do skeletons call their friends how
do skeletons call their phone
i'm not too sure on the scalabone i'm
just gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three
and the other is called under 12. who
won depends who's the fastest cat
one two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness tells why do you make a nice
cup of tea for nanny
you want me to disappear thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
mm-hmm
nice quarter these jokes they get worse
oh she's only having a bit of fun sauce
worcester sauce
that's gonna give that really nice spicy
seasoning
oh thank you okay yeah
tomato puree in you could put a ton of
tomatoes in this if you want
you could yeah put that mince back in
there once it's drained
i'm just going to put a little touch i
know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really why the red wine well because i'm
going to make it nice and rich
okay produce the red wine down yeah
and then start covering your with your
stock
now i'm gonna bring that up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay like it'll taste yes please
is it hot it's a little bit hot be
careful
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it'll be delicious
trust me now good spring onions
we'll chop up and that's going to go
through the mashed potatoes it's going
to sit on top of that nicer i like that
savory yeah delicious mince that's laced
with all that red wine
nice so sprinkles into there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello oh hi jack hi hi
hello hello jack have a nice day school
yeah
yeah so we'll dry out those potatoes and
then mash them
no oh can i mash them would you okay um
holly slice a little knob of butter in
there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cookie
exactly that not really
you used to help me as little right
you kids do no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy are they
aren't they and do you want mom look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah seriously
brings back good memories no
just why'd you do that dad i just wanted
to fork it to get it nice and
spiky so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top
and that goes in the oven literally 20
minutes 180
minutes jack can you on the door please
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this
is no different but with a modern twist
braised peas and carrots with a
fantastic homemade mint butter
shepherd's pie glazed on top
that looks lovely doesn't it and then
the carrots
that's why i didn't put carrots in let's
put them on the side i'll see
last job before serving pour that
gorgeous butterscotch sauce
over the pudding okay i'll take one at a
time
that smells incredible this is my
ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now
this is incredible there's the shoulder
yeah
and look there's the shoulder blade if
you go through here there's a knuckle
there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called
a butt the slower you cook it the more
juicy it is
and it's great for big parties because
you just come along and get your fork
and shred it a delicious
smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay i'm gonna
leave the roots on
okay because i want this to sit
underneath the pore
it gives it a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now
i'll peel the garlic okay i'd like you
and to crush the garlic we're gonna make
a really nice little paste
okay go on maggie
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more crush come on miggy
now this is a beauty
paprika smoked paprika i love it so
three nice tablespoons
in okay two
large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please and pepper could go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now olive oil
in
mix that some thyme in there so we've
got a sort of fragrant
rub time stalks underneath
so that's even more flavor going on on
the bottom pour that
all over it now this is where you've got
to be really quick
okay and sort of rub that mashed sausage
in almost
exactly that smells amazing
honestly you just drizzle a little touch
of olive on top of that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinading of the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if i was
doing this for a sunday
and start marinating thursday friday so
it gets even tastier
right quite easy as well to make it's
very easy five and a half to six hours
in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are going to pimp some shot-bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you have to twist
to us
yeah there's so many things something
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness
but there's some heat coming okay and
i've got a little bit
off you love this chipotle smoked
chipotle paste
i love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah you can
use it for any sandwiches really any
sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
i've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's our nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready
just time to knock up a couple of tried
and tested party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water
skins and all meanwhile finely dice
sweet pickled gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty gruyere cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush
and add your spring onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling
of grated greer these simple cheesy
crushed potatoes are equally delicious
served hot or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make
a really nice fresh broccoli salad now
these are called
florets and that's the best part of the
broccoli
okay the bit that everybody wants once
they're off i'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay mm-hmm never had raw broccoli
before
it's always been cooked really when you
dress this with the dressing
it's incredible now a little season
early on yeah okay now for the dressing
fresh yogurt in a teaspoon of sugar
please daddy
a little smell cider vinegar mmm there
you go
finely chop shallot in with the broccoli
so delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
currants i love them that gives that
nice sort of chewy texture
all right lift up your bowl please nice
and gently half of that
in the middle please thank you and stop
and then mix that up with me
a little taste
so good and this kind of salad it
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow for
this look at this
megan honestly that is amazing
it's beautiful that is incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that i
thought let's have a tiny bit
just before we go to the table just a
little bit
honestly meg don't tell mom
thank you honestly do i do it i'm gonna
do it
that is incredible so good you promise
me
you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go come on
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cook smokey
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
first job i have pomegranate marinade
for the quail which have been cut in
half and flattened
so small aren't they small yeah it's
tiny so it's almost like a sort of nice
entrance into eating something slightly
gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt and pepper and all
spatchcock means is the rib cage has
been taken out and they're flattened
down
and because the bird is so delicate it's
flattened to cook evenly
and it really is a nice sort of
light gamey dense chicken flavor
so we're toaster spices when you think
of middle eastern food it's packed with
amazing flavors tablespoon of coriander
a teaspoon of cumin
and a nice little seasoning of salt so
we toast them now
intensifying the flavor when they start
smoking lightly
that's a nice indication that they're
ready
okay if you grind away so the best thing
there let's just stand up close today
thank you oh look your tummy's out
i thought it was a quail tummy this hand
here
keeps it nice and firm and you grind
that into a nice powder for belly please
smells so good doesn't it yeah so to get
that
in really go around the outside and that
grinds it up
i've gone around the pestle mortar more
times than you kiss boys
squeeze the garlic in next
a little glove
okay then i want you to pour six
tablespoons please
so that is pomegranate molasses
so it's like an aged parsley vinegar but
really reduced down
give that a nice mix up is it going to
be very sweet dad a little taste
it's sweet but sour yeah it is
it's so good though no take
a nice spoon put it inside
the quail you can even do this the night
before
because you pop them in the fridge let
the quail marinate anywhere from half an
hour to overnight
for my ultimate middle eastern dessert
it's got to be baklava
start by melting butter in a pan
chop pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combine with caster sugar and lemon
zest
[Music]
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray
place half a sheet of phyllo pastry on
the base
brush well with melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix repeat
and press down between layers
you're looking to create 30 to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut the baklava into bite-sized
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30 to 40 minutes
meanwhile make your delicious citrusy
syrup
simply add water to a pan along with
caster sugar
and the zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar
has fully dissolved now to give the
cloud a wonderful sweetness
remove from the oven and whilst hot pour
over the syrup
so each layer is gloriously sticky leave
the paklava to absorb the syrup for at
least 12 hours
these delicious sticky treats will keep
for a week
but they're so moorish they'll be gone
in a flash
the quails have marinated now they're
ready to cook
nice hot pan pick up your quail
and skin side down first okay
get all that nice color and always open
them up as well
in the pan okay we'll get that skin
crisp crispy that's right smell that
pomegranate
i can really smell it it smells so good
you get all that marinade in there
you know cook with it as well don't
waste it how long on average does it
take to cook could you say
literally 12-15 minutes in the oven
a little touch of water in
bring that up to the ball into the oven
180 so 12 to 15 minutes
[Applause]
okay the final job before serving
a herby butter bean salad to go with my
quail in pomegranate molasses
now one of the things that i love about
middle eastern salads is the sort of
crunch
and the color as well butter beans it's
gonna be the base
of our salad from their little radishes
and sort of top and tail them get them
like that
and throw them in there's nothing small
and dainty in there
okay yeah so with the spring onions
nice we're gonna use the greens and the
whites i'm gonna slice
along that way this time to get those
nice light shards okay
yeah now
the croutons are made out of these
little
pita breads just slice lengthways in
with the salad oh yes
so this salad is all about texture so
cucumber okay
and take out the seeds how come you're
taking the seeds out
it just makes the salad very watery
like a shower okay cucumber juice
delicious i guess you go yeah you got me
going you really got me going no no
no oh yeah i've got revision to be doing
don't worry this is far more important
trust me
who needs exams where you can cook for a
living
you gave me with my exams it's fine it's
fine it's fine be a chef for a living
have a proper job don't take your things
out like that you'll be thumbless let's
go
now your cucumber in from there
take your nice vibrant tomatoes slice
down
it almost looks like a greek salad as
those colors it resembles that that's
right
and with the celery like before yeah
lengthways
so we need some mint and parsley i want
you sprinkling it in there
and really mix it through the herbs give
it that nice kind of freshness
but i want a bit of a bite in there now
i love pomegranate
so just carefully open that up
okay and then just dot them on top so we
got a bit of fruitiness now into the
salad
for crunch simply cut up whole pita
breads fry in a really hot pan with
olive oil until wonderfully golden
crispy and irresistible
out into a
sieve
okay next a sprinkle of sumac
that's a dried fruit from middle east
the zest of a lemon and the juice
then a drizzle of olive oil and last but
not least
my crunchy pitter croutons let's make
the croutons on well they've gotten hard
oh just lift that up and mix in your
hands there
nice and juicy just with fingertips
there you go so you just mix there you
go
it doesn't crush anything it doesn't
crush anything but then let's just take
a little bean wow isn't that delicious
mm-hmm nice now quail
it's got that really sort of toasted
almost like
a sort of light smells so good barbecue
flavor
can't wait to try it
beef wow and then just finely
a bit of lemon zest it just lightens
everything up a little bit
and it goes so well with the pomegranate
now just
wow that'll smell better than any
boyfriend you'll ever have
oh my god i beg to differ
okay good let's go how delicious is that
so delicious
my middle eastern feast of quail with a
pomegranate molasses and butter bean
salad with batava to follow
when dishes are this aromatic and
colorful there's no wonder
that middle eastern food is always a hit
you